if you're in sales you like that
competition but also it's helping people
grow
and and that's it's not just the money
it's also your career
[Music]
all right andy cohen thank you for being
on my show how are you i'm great how are
you doing michael
i i am just fine how have you been
dealing with this whole covert situation
working from home
yeah you know it's been great my company
that i'm working for now bill.com we
sell
a cloud application for paying your
bills where you're not in your office so
we're we're living by that
we're we're 600 people all working
remotely and
haven't missed a beat so go to bed well
and i'm getting
uh more time with my family which is
nice so i'm uh i'm
i'm doing great and i love it okay so so
you know
just start off svp of sales at build.com
600 person company working remotely
give me like your two cents on on what
what were the some of the most
you know meaningful leadership changes
that that occurred
as we transitioned from you know in
office to to all working from home
as you're in an executive within within
a 600 person company what were some of
your personal you know
challenges or changes that you had to
adapt to yeah so i run a sales team with
bill.com
um we're we really thrive off each
other's energy
we're we're mostly together in palo alto
in a bullpen high fiving ringing the
gong having a great time when we close
deals wait there's an actual gang
oh of course there's a gun um and so
you know what i was worried when when we
got the one week notice to go remote is
how do you keep that energy because
so much of sales is the energy and um
i'm just so proud and grateful to the
team that we've been able to replicate a
lot
of that online not all of it but a lot
of that so with one week notice
everybody goes home and it's it's people
in their 20s and 30s that
don't all have the best work environment
they were they're sometimes still living
with their parents or they're in crowded
apartments and so
everybody scrambled um fortunately um
we're all busy because bill.com is an
application that small businesses use to
pay bills
remotely and so it's tailor made for
being remote uh
business but also we've every day we do
zoom stand-ups we've done
we do zoom happy hours we even did a
quota club dinner where i sent everybody
steak and a bottle of wine and we all
have jelly together
and so we're trying to do as much as we
can and i think long term we all
want to be back together again but for
short term you know we're making it work
i think that i think that that's
incredible i think it's always
fascinating to hear how different
companies transition to this time
especially
coming in from a leadership position
where you know a lot of i'm sure that
people are looking up at you and saying
okay well andy what what do we do now
how is our culture going to look like
every person comes in with their own you
know
set of deliberations and and and worries
but andy i want to go back a little bit
and you know
he did a stanford kellogg a transition
to
deloitte different startups and
caring.com when i saw
caring.com and your and your involvement
with it
i got so inspired i'm very passionate
about about the
about you know the the issue of of
help using technology to help to help
those that are aging and especially
looking at you know my own family
and how you know it's very it's getting
more and more difficult to have coherent
communication
and to take care of them especially as
we're in a remote setting where it's not
ideal to go
just go and visit and be with them all
the time talk to me a little bit about
the founding of
and founding and management of
caring.com and where that went
yeah and just backing up a little bit
michael my my view on the business
career
is you know a lot of people i think
start their career and they want to have
a plan i want to do this for five years
this for five years
i'm going to get these skills and it's
going to enable to do this and i look at
the
the business career as as as 30
having the skills and 70 percent
reacting to opportunities when my i'm
i'm
56 i've had a 30-year 35-year business
career
you know and it's sort of like a white
water rafting if you're down a river
and there's rocks and you're navigating
you can know how to paddle the boat you
can have a good boat
but you don't know what's around the
corner and so i think
as you know if i was giving advice to
young people i'd be like get all the
skills and be prepared but you're right
you're
riding down a wild river you don't know
what's around the corner
but you can when you see the smooth
water you can go for it
when you see the waterfall you can avoid
it you just have to be prepared but
it's only 30 percent under your control
is going to be the river and how you
react to it that's my view on business
so
caring.com was one of those situations i
um
was in the the position of losing both
my parents
uh at a young age my dad had a heart
attack and died at 67.
um and then my mom got lung cancer
shortly thereafter she was living in
chicago i was living in silicon valley
i was in a demanding job and i was
flying back and forth trying to help her
on the weekends and um it was an awful
time
because i loved my mom very much and we
were very close it was
horrible watching her struggle and then
it was also horrible i was a
mba smart business guy trying to help
her navigate the health care system
trying to help her try to hire a nurse
navigate medicare
um you know deal with end of life and i
just felt so unprepared and after
she passed away it was awful i ended up
taking time off
and kept talking to other people and
said well how did you
how did you deal with all this end of
life stuff when you when you're planning
your wedding
you can talk to your parents you can
find all these websites when you're
having a baby you can read books but
when you're losing a parent it's very
difficult
how do you know what to do and everybody
told me that had lost a parent
they had no idea what to do so i said
hey there's websites for
wedding planning there's websites for
having a baby there should be a website
for caring for aging parent and it's
tough stuff but if you can help someone
you're doing god's work you're
you're you're helping them through
probably the most difficult period in
their life
losing losing a parent so i started
caring.com with that mission
um and it wasn't that i had this whole
business plan that i said okay there's
an aging population there's going to be
a lot of caregivers this is going to be
a big
business it was like hey i went through
this horrible experience and i knew that
i could help people through this website
and so startingcaring.com for me
turned out to be a very good business
opportunity but it was also very
cathartic for me as a way to get over my
grief
and then it also was a way to really get
a great team together because what i
learned is when you have a mission-based
company
um you can get great great people that
are there
because they really believe in the
mission and so we had an awesome team at
karen.com that
you know i had no trouble attracting the
best engineers keeping the best
engineers
um you know we were venture-backed so we
were able to pay market rate but also
people really liked the culture and the
mission and so that was such a wonderful
uh period i was founded it grew it sold
it after seven years
um because i'd raised venture we needed
an exit but through that seven years you
know
had very little turnover and a great
culture and great fun and i'm
so proud anything i did before or after
that's the proudest
part of my career was starting a
mission-based company and helping
we ended up getting three million
visitors a month of people that were
struggling with caregiving and we were
able to help them make it a little
easier
wow that's incredible so give me a
little bit of insight into this into you
know this
this market right now so so when you're
talking about the difficulties of
taking care of aging parents or
grandparents what what are the
difficulties
is it the lack of information that's out
there the lack of resources the lack of
you know matching with the right people
to help take care of them
what are the biggest difficulties there
before you before you came into
karen.com and perhaps today onwards yeah
so
for the answer is yes there it's all
it's all difficult
and unlike other life events you know
you have no one to go to for advice
because if you're
let me give you the numbers so there's
there's roughly in the u.s 2 million
weddings
a year and and people know that you know
you spend fifty thousand
fifty thousand dollars on a wedding two
million weddings there's probably three
million
babies born a year in the u.s uh roughly
spent a lot of money on a baby
there's 45 million people caring for an
aging parent in the u.s
and and and and it's going that
caregiving period is
is a five-year journey on average where
the parent is less
independent and needs the adult child to
help them they're spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars on
on housing on meals on equipment on
procedures
um 85 percent of medicare spending is on
the last
year of life so it's just a very
expensive difficult emotionally drained
and
all your other life events you go to
your parents you say hey help me with my
wedding help me with my baby
you you can't say help me carry for you
and your death because they don't
they don't want any help they want to be
independent so it's just super difficult
all above and so
from a business standpoint there's lots
of areas where
i think there's opportunity on helping
making this easier both for the
caregiver as well as for the senior
but a lot of it is for the caregiver how
do you help them help their parents
via technology via services and this is
a worldwide
uh issue because people are living
longer but they're not living
necessarily independently
long they're living in in less
independent conditions and now with the
issues with coven and senior housing not
being safe
more people are going to be aging and
home and so they're going to need more
technology and services so i think
anyone is interested in this space
you know there's lots of opportunity and
it's really nice
if you've got your your mission and
there's margin as a business person you
can overlap those two
and you can you don't have to get grants
you can do something you can do god's
work and and
have it be a business and i think how
many opportunities that's incredible
i've been passionate for so long
most recently i was at a y combinator
hackathon where we developed an app
where we can
you know install and a gadget on the com
on the
on my grandma's tv and we can then
through our phone click a button it
calls her tv and she just has to raise
her hand in order to answer the call
because you know lack of dexterity and
lack of you know tech understanding
but and and i became so passionate about
this you know this problem where
you you just the lack of communication
and the barriers that are rising between
the new generations and the older
generations are so apparent
that you know you know you're looking at
you know the last years i'm looking even
you know in the last 20 years when
they're healthy and fine
but they're not really able to
communicate with the grandkids and you
know loneliness is one of the
greatest difficulties of that age so i'm
i
and i think it's one of the most
underserved you know markets out there
and i can't wait for for
for people or myself to go and solve
that so i completely agree with you
yeah definitely andy i want to take us
now to
your now most current role so you
transition and and
you what you mentioned was that you are
not so you're svp of sales in build.com
but it actually started
then you were you were a customer of
theirs for a long time you loved the
product
and you make that transition right yeah
so this is where i talked about you know
business career i think is a
is a river you're just sailing along and
so i sold my company caring.com
had a good outcome was trying to think
of what to do next and i was having
lunch with my friend
renee lesert who had started a company
called bill.com and i knew bill.com well
because
i was one of their first customers and i
used it at caring.com
i also was an investor in the company
and so i was having lunch with renee
saying hey
i'm not sure what i want to do next i
had this wonderful experience with karen
i had a good outcome and he said hey why
don't you come help me at build.com
we're
growing the company we want to go public
i need someone to run sales you'd be
great at that and i said you know
i'm i'm i wasn't looking to go be head
of sales but i liked renee
i like the company's good product with
that yeah let me let me do this for a
year this could be fun
and that was four years ago it's been a
ton of fun we we've
taken grown the company you know 500
percent we've taken it public
it's been a really good outcome but i
wasn't looking for that right that was
just something that came along it was a
good opportunity i jumped on it
it's been very good for me um
financially and it's been fun
to be part of uh ipo getting that
experience but
but i wasn't it was again wasn't my plan
it was like here's a good opportunity
um it just worked out so give me a few
insights about sales what is it like to
to run sale team
what are some of the you know i'm not
coming from my sales background at all
as an engineer myself yet
almost every single person that i meet
that i ask what is your number one
advice for me
would you say you know any advice to any
young entrepreneur learn how to
be and learn how to sell learn how to be
a good salesman
not in the you know necessarily like the
bad connotation of the word but
but be able to communicate your message
effectively and convince others of why
your idea matters
so i'd love to hear your opinion on that
yeah and then i never
you know when i was in business schools
sales was a four-letter word right you
didn't want to get into sales you wanted
to be in marketing that was where the
strategic smart people went into
marketing uh the hustlers went into
sales so in my start of my career i was
a marketer a product manager as vp of
marketing
um but during once when i was a vp of
marketing i would help out with the
sales and
um we went i was at a startup where we
went through seven vps of sales and each
time we
fired one the ceo said hey can you help
you you know the product can you go in
and try to close the deals i'd go in and
close the deals
and after the seventh one was fired he
said hey every time we fire when you go
in and you close the deals why don't you
just run sales so
i learned how to run sales that way and
i realized
it was really the most important
function at a company because
um you really whether your product is
great or not
you've got to get revenue for it to keep
the company going and those sales skills
really helped me when i was a ceo
because
when you're a ceo it's 100 sales you're
selling investors you're selling the
first employees you're selling the first
customers
and so that sales skill is super
valuable as an entrepreneur
not just because sales is such an
important function but also because
sales you're selling as a ceo all the
time and so
i was fortunate to be able to be an
interim vp of sales learn
how important it was and then use that
skill uh as my own company and then
this this sales job i have now is
actually the first pure sales job i've
ever had
i've been a vp marketing i've been a gm
i've been a ceo and um but i had those
skills so i was able to do it
so then how does somebody you know the
growing trend is that more and more you
know young entrepreneurs are coming from
an engineering background
and they're they're very focused on the
technology how does one like myself go
and actually acquire these hands-on
skills and and then ability to sell it
doesn't sound like there's you know
a good class i could take at stanford
called how to sell you how how to sell
yeah because no one would take the class
because they all think they don't want
to do it
it should be that class by the way i
think it would be one of the best
classes at stanford but i don't think
there is one
well i think i think you might have to
come and teach it i would
i would definitely take it but now
seriously i mean i'm going through my
journey
and how does a young entrepreneur like
myself go and you know practice
this practice these these hands-on
skills and gets better at it
yeah so um you know the nice thing about
sales is you did is
if you're if you're empathetic and a
good listener you'll you can you can
learn
how to do it but if you start a company
you are going to learn that your job is
sales
so as an entrepreneur i think going into
it know that if you decide to start a
company
your job is going to be sales the
product part is easier
the harder part is is the investors and
the employees and the first
customers especially those first
customers that are just buying on the
mission
because version one of your product
isn't going to solve their problem
it's going to give them a path to
solving a problem and so you really have
to convince them but
you know you're you're be surprised how
much selling you do in your life do you
have a girlfriend
yeah wife yeah i have a girlfriend all
right
you're selling you're selling hard all
the time right
so i think part of it is just learning
that you're selling all the time anyways
and the formal sales part is just a
title really because
everything you do in your life is sales
whether it's relationships whether it's
uh friendships whether it's uh investors
you're you are michael probably a very
good salesman
thank you no no and then definitely you
know i i do think that you know growing
up
with you know in the entrepreneurship
world i do notice that the world
the four-letter word does have some
negative connotation but i'm definitely
thinking too hard what you're saying and
this idea that at the end
you know selling it's not just going and
trying to get people to pay money for
something it's this whole idea of how do
you
how do you get people excited about
something that you're bringing to the
table whether it's investors or
employees or
or or you know your actual product etc
but andy and then you're running you
know an organization of
sales people and one of the things that
i'm always curious about is you know in
sales it always seems like it's
very you know compensate like you know
the commission driven incentive
like i want to sell so that i can i want
to show that i sold the most so and that
means that i'm the best
how do you create a healthy culture that
that does have you know these
motivations but you know is also mission
driven
as a part of a hundred person
organization yeah so you know it's
important
as a company and renee has done a great
job of build.com of creating a great
mission focus we're helping businesses
operate
in the cloud right and you know we've
always been focused on that in the last
six months we're super focused on it so
we're actually helping small businesses
manage their cash flow and stay in
business during these crazy times so
my sales team has that same mission
we're really helping small businesses
and then for motivating sales people
yeah it's the money but it's also
your career what do you want to learn
what how do you want to grow do you want
to maximize your income
or do you want to be a vp of sales
someday and so we spent a lot of time on
my
team helping people grow and telling
you know explaining to them it's not
just the comp it's also you know how do
you get to the next level what skills do
you learn so we do a lot of promoting
from within
where we'll take people that are just
starting their sales career and get them
to more senior selling positions or get
them to manage your position
so a lot of it is just making sure we
understand what people's goals are
and then helping them achieve their
dreams whether it's money or
responsibility or sales skills so we do
a lot
of that and that's how we keep the team
you know motivated
sure we're also trying to have
competitions and
and every day we have a leaderboard
stack ranked on who's on top and who's
not
if you're in sales you like that
competition but also it's helping people
grow
and and that's it's not just the money
it's also your career
you know how do you feel you don't feel
that the
competitive side of it is taking is
eating away from the mission side of it
or creating a hostile environment
you're saying it actually you know it
just helps you be more diligent
and focus more on on what your what your
motivations are
and your responsibility as a leader of
such teams is to help
people navigate what are their
motivations and how do you help them get
there
in the easiest way possible yeah yeah i
mean it could be cutthroat but it
doesn't have to be cutthroat
right and then and then back to selling
a lot of selling that people don't
understand it's not it's not telling
someone it's it's asking them questions
so when we
we use an application called chorus
where we we tape
uh people sales calls so that we can
understand uh help them do better
train them and the good ones it's the
customer
or the prospect talking more than the
rep so a good rep is asking you five or
six key questions
and then leading you to okay if you've
got if you answer this way
you need our product if you answer so
you don't so a good salesperson in life
or is asking the right questions finding
out how to help the person they're
talking to
and then providing a solution to that
problem so selling is really helping
people
at a fundamental level if you have a
problem where you're uh
spending um three people to to open
envelopes and write checks
and sign checks and it's costing you a
lot of money we can help you
save money and make your process more
efficient we're helping you so good good
sales is
finding a problem and solving it it's
not convincing someone to do something
that they shouldn't do
and you know obviously you know one of
the most you know greatest changes that
covet is bringing upon us
is this whole nature of sales and while
you know in my mind i'm imagining
a a sales you know relationship is that
you go you meet in person you maybe go
out for you maybe go out for dinner you
demo the product in person
and as a sales person you're able to
gauge the other person's you know
how they're how receptive they are to
what you're saying now you have to do a
lot of this over zoom
and is is there differences are there
more difficulties where are we headed in
terms of the whole sales cycle
yeah so fortunately for us we were doing
it over zoom anyways so it wasn't really
a change we're all prepared
i'm probably not the best person to
answer that question yeah no no
definitely but
it is something i think that i've been
thinking about how do you take you know
a lot of the core relationships that
that we have in our daily lives and now
they're transitioned over zoom and you
want to
remain receptive and actually you know i
have i have some friends who are
thinking about how do you actually you
know
leverage the fact that these
conversations are over
zoom so that you can get even more
insight into your cell cycle
like what like what's happening with
course well i will tell you people have
more time to talk to you you know we're
doing outbound
um and people are spending less time in
meetings and they're more available to
have these conversations and they're
also i think i'm thinking more out of
the box than they were pre-covet on are
there better ways to do things so i
think
for innovative technologies is a great
time i love it i love it andy
this was so great i learned so much i
want to thank you again for your time
before we leave i want to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
yeah so i mean uh you'd have to ask my
wife for the truth but i'll tell you
what i think of myself
so i think determined i think it's all
about persistence life is 99
persistence yeah you know so i i am
persistent
i'm also optimistic because i think uh
in in business you have to be
there's everything is always broken and
nothing is ever
perfect and so you have to be optimistic
um so i think persistent and optimistic
and then um the the other thing is you
know i'm just
uh at this point i would say that i'm
i've uh
i'm focused on on non-work as well and
just having a balanced life so
i think persistent uh optimistic and
just focused on
on balance too which i love
energy to to do the work my high school
principal was always saying balance
balance balance by the time we graduated
we all knew
we all knew that phrase like in the back
of our hands
and you know we're talking about balance
also you know involved with with j
ventures and early stage investing and
then helping other
young companies grow up so we didn't
even get to talk about that but but i i
love this idea and i and i learned so
much so thank you again andy
and this is really fantastic michael
thank you pleasure to meet you and
hopefully our paths will cross again
in person someday because that is still
important 100 100
thank you andy all right thank you take
care bye bye